[Musique]
j'entends souvent cette phrase
l'habitat participatif
ça n'est pas pour
pourquoi ça me surprend à chaque fois
quand mon fils se retrouvent face et une
assiette avec des aliments qui ne
connaît pas et qui me dit j'aime pas je
lui dis mon chéri tu ne peux pas dire
que tu n'aimes pas tant que tu n'as pas
goûté
je vais tenter lors de cette conférence
de vous faire goûter un petit bout
d'habitat participatif
tenez prenez un bout et fait passer
alors d'abord accordons-nous sur les
termes qu'est-ce que l'habitat
participatif
horse en donne une définition elle dit
grosse somme si c'est une démarche
citoyenne qui permet à des personnes de
se réunir pour définir concevoir
acquérir et gérer leur logement avec des
espaces individuels et des espaces
communs
on parle parfois d'habitat partagé
l'habitat groupé l'habitat coopératif
certains collectifs se reconnaissent
dans les termes d'oise is
d'écovillages déco lieu
moi j'utilise habitat participatif parce
que c'est le terme qui est dans la loi
française et je trouve ça plutôt classe
mais finalement peu importe ce dont je
vais vous parler c'est un art de vivre
ensemble une autre manière d'habiter qui
nécessite de construire à la fois un
collectif et un lieu de vie
l'association habitat participatif
france et la coopérative oasis ont créé
une carte qui recense les projets en
france
il y à l'heure actuelle 9 116 projets
dont 315 sont aboutis
moi je vis en habitat participatif
depuis dix ans je suis fondatrice ou
plus exactement cofondatrice nous avons
acheté un ancien corps de ferme dans une
zone péri urbaine de lyon
nous l'avons au torino v pour y faire
sept logements et des espaces communs là
où avant il n'y avait qu'une seule
famille
notre collectif s'appelle les choulans
les habitants sont des choux les enfants
sont des chouquettes ceux qui viennent
nous aider à bruz bricoler sont des
brocolis et c'est
alors comment j'en suis arrivée là j'ai
fait une école d'ingénieurs pas
n'importe laquelle
j'ai développer les énergies
renouvelables pendant plusieurs années
et puis en 2009 2010 je suis parti un an
voyage en asie en afrique
nous étions quatre dans l' aventure et
nous allions à la rencontre de mode de
vie traditionnel pour nous inspirer dans
notre manière de vivre en france
nous avons pris le temps de voyager sans
avion
de nous ouvrir à d'autres cultures sans
juger
et puis nous avons appris à nous écouter
nous copé et coopérer au quotidien à 4
ce voyage a été profondément
transformateurs
j'ai acquis la conviction que le bonheur
ne vient pas des biens matériels mais
des relations humaines authentiques que
l'on peut tisser
au revenant je me suis questionnée sur
ce que j'avais vraiment envie de faire
et c'est vers l'habitat participatif que
je me suis tournée d'abord à titre
personnel en créant le projet des choux
blanc puis bien plus tard à titre
professionnel maintenant j'accompagne
des groupes et des particuliers qui
veulent vivre en habitat participatif
et j'ai même écrit un livre sur le sujet
moi je n'ai jamais fait le choix de
vivre en collectif en fait je n'ai pas
fait le choix de vivre seul pour moi le
collectif n'est pas un choix mais une
évidence et j'ai bien vu lors de mon
voyage que l'habitat individuel n'est
pas la norme pas partout bien au
contraire
j'ai vécu de nombreuses années en
colocation
j'y voyais les avantages les
inconvénients
et pour moi l'habitat participatif
élimine la plupart des inconvénients de
la colocation pourquoi parce qu'on a le
choix
on a le choix de l'habitat on a le choix
des valeurs qu'on veut partager le choix
du mode de financement
et le choix évidemment du collectif et
de son organisation
je reviendrai sur chacun de ces points
alors tout le monde n'a pas le même
attrait que moi à vivre en collectif
cependant je pense que l'habitat
participatif peut correspondre à
beaucoup de monde
au niveau de l'habitat tout d'abord je
me disais que dans la loi lure il est
dit que des personnes se réunissent pour
définir et concevoir leur habitat ça se
ressent au niveau des espaces communs
honnêtement parmi vous est ce qu'il ya
des gens qui voient un inconvénient à
mutualiser une buanderie des chambres
d'amis un atelier bricolage une grande
salle polyvalente un jardin
au chou blanc nous avons tout ça et même
plus
nous avons également une cuisine et un
salon commun pourtant nous avons des
cuisines et des salons privés chez nous
dans notre projet nous avons fait le
choix de diminuer au maximum nos espaces
individuels pour nous offrir de beaux
espaces communs résultat mon appartement
est parfaitement dimensionné pour ma
famille 65 m² à 4 mais dès qu'on reçoit
du monde on se retrouve à l'e3
je vois la cuisine et le salon commun
comme des
extensions mon appartement alors que la
grande salle commune qu'on appelle chez
nous le trait d'union est plus un lieu
de d'événements exceptionnels des
grandes fêtes des soirées ou des
réunions avec des personnes extérieures
les espaces communs font la richesse de
notre collectif ça donne tellement de
possibilités
l'autre jour nous avons reçu trois
groupes de musique en répétition chacun
porté par un cohabitant je fais une
petite parenthèse j'utilise le terme
cohabitant pour parler des autres
membres de mon collectif bah oui parce
qu'ils sont à double mélange entre
voisins amis et famille fallait bien
nouveaux termes pour exprimer cette
nuance
et donc je disais trois groupes de
musique il y avait du jazz cubain dans
le salon commun il y avait un atelier de
musique klezmer dans le trait d'union et
il y avait un groupe de musique
chilienne révolutionnaire chez un de mes
cohabitant au moment du goûter tout le
monde s'est retrouvé sur la terrasse
commune avec les cohabitants qu'il
souhaitait y avait une sacrée ambiance
chaque projet est unique dans son
habitat mais également dans ses valeurs
par exemple vous pouvez avoir un projet
en milieu rural qui va porter très fort
un projet sociétal engagés dans la non
spéculation offrant des logements à prix
abordable dans des quartiers qu'ils ne
permettaient plus
ou bien un projet tourné vers
l'autonomie alimentaire qui va associer
habitat et activités agricoles
chaque projet a sa propre couleur
je vous partage et quelques valeurs que
nous avons sous laon
l'expérimentation écologique pour nous
c'est expérimenté l'écologie à la fois
dans l'habitat mais également dans les
modes de vie
l'expérimentation sociale
c'est prendre des décisions en
équivalence mais également choisir un
montage juridique qui favorise le
collectif plutôt que l'individu et qui
limite la spéculation immobilière
l'ouverture se concrétise pour nous par
des événements culturels ouverts sur le
village et l'investissement de nos
membres dans des associations dans la
commune
l'accueil des migrants ne faisait pas
partie de nos valeurs initiales c'est
quelque chose qui a été portée par
quelques cohabitant par la suite
au début de notre projet nous voulions
quelque chose de rapide et pragmatique
du coup nous avons appliqué la règle les
personnes qui sont là sont les bonnes
personnes et on avance
du coup notre projet n'est pas parfait
mais il a été rapide nous l'avons monté
en trois ans en moyenne
alors certaines valeurs se retrouvent
régulièrement dans les projets allaient
tenez parmi ce que je vais vous dire est
ce qu'il ya des choses qui vous parle
avoir un mode de vie plus écologique
[Musique]
mutualiser des espaces mais également
des services comme une flotte de
véhicules par exemple
avoir de l'entr'aide au quotidien
ne pas vieillir seul mélanger les
générations
allez un peu plus engagé
être solidaire avec les plus démunis
comme des familles ukrainienne par
exemple
je vois qu'il y en a certains qui sont
prêts à vivre en habitat participatif
à peut-être que ceux qui se disent que
l'habitat participatif ça n'est pas pour
eux pensent qu'il ya un problème au
niveau financier
alors là je vous arrête tout de suite
tout est possible en habitat
participatif on peut parfaitement être
propriétaire de son logement
actuellement un tiers des projets sont
montés en copropriété on peut
parfaitement également être locataire
d'un bailleur social ou alors créer
ensemble une structure dans laquelle on
est locataire ou dans laquelle on a
lusage de son logement alors je ne vais
pas rentrer dans les détails des
montages juridiques mais ce que je vous
j'ai envie de vous dire c'est que
l'aspect financier n'est pas un blocage
pour vivre ainsi
l'habitat participatif
c'est un art de vivre pas un montage
juridique
au passage vous voyez qu'avec tout ce
qu'il faut définir à entre les valeurs
les espaces mutualisés le montage
juridique ce genre de projet ne se
montrent pas en deux jours
non ce que je crois c'est que ceux qui
ont peur de vivre en habitat
participatifs ont des projections ils
ont peur du collectif peur des autres
ils ont peur de tomber sur une personne
toxiques qui va leur pourrir la vie
que le collectif les contraigne les
force à faire des choses qu'ils n'ont
pas envie de faire
tenez parmi vous qui a peur de vivre
avec d'autres personnes lever la main
eh bien oui c'est normal
moi mon expérience du collectif ça n'est
pas ça en tout cas ce n'est pas que ça
j'ai envie de vous partager quelques
exemples
[Musique]
vincent revient de vacances il est seul
avec ses enfants les valises chargées il
arrive à la gare à deux kilomètres de
chez nous il envoie un petit message
l'un d'eux nous descend en voiture
voiture mutualisé évidemment pour aller
chercher
voilà comment mettre un petit peu
d'huile dans les rouages
l'entr'aide ce peut être aussi plus
engagée par exemple comme mon fils avait
trois semaines il a fait une
bronchiolite il a fallu qu'on l'emmène à
l'hôpital en pleine nuit
pour ne pas réveiller notre grande fille
nous avons demandé à notre cohabitante
sophie de venir finir sa nuit chez nous
le lendemain matin sophie a pris en
charge notre fille puis l'a passée à
michel nous nous étions sereins nous
savions qu'elle était entre de bonnes
mains et nous pouvions nous concentrer
sur les soins portés à notre fils
et cohabitant ne sont pas tous des amis
et ce sont des personnes sur qui je peux
compter et ça ça change tout
il ya aussi des moments en léger
conviviaux hier midi par exemple avec
bruno et léa on a pris un repas ensemble
bruno et moi on télétravail en général
et léa est en congé maternité alors en
semaine on aime bien manger en sang
bruno a descendu du riz qu'il avait dans
son frigo les à cuisiner une fondue de
poireaux et à pour s'est retrouvé au
soleil en terrasse pour prendre notre
repas
faciles léger que du bonheur
parfois on mange aussi les mythes dès
dimanche midi dans ce cas là il ya plus
de monde surtout plus d'enfants vincent
nous fait son célèbre poule et fritz
chacun trouve sa place dans
l'organisation
certains se mettent les pieds sous la
table mais c'est pas grave ils font la
vaisselle
c'est un joyeux bordel
je peux participer à ces rassemblements
mais je peux aussi choisir de rester
chez moi dans ma grotte car l'habitat
participatif 7 à géométrie variable et
ses cantons seulement canton
auch où l'on nous avons beaucoup d'ours
de ce type
là arrive parfois que je ne vois pas
certain qu habitants pendant plusieurs
jours à plusieurs semaines trop de
travail à l'envi de d'entamer une
conversation envie de rester toute la
journée sous la couette
peu importe les raisons en fait chacun
est libre
et quand je les croise en terrasse pour
boire un verre ou manger ensemble je
sais qu'ils sont dans un esprit
d'ouverture l'envi de discuter
mais tout ça n'est pas automatique le
vivre ensemble ça s'apprend ça se
construit petit à petit
écouter les autres censures réagir
entendre et des avis différents
construire ensemble une solution qui
prenne en compte les besoins de chacun
auch où l'on nous utilisons la prise de
décisions par consentement c'est à la
fois un processus à suivre
collectivement et une posture individuel
à adopter
et quand on ya goûté
quand on sait que l'intelligence
collective fait qu'on est plus créatif
et plus forts ensemble que chacun dans
son coin alors on peut plus s'en passer
car moi je ne peux plus m'en passer
il arrive que j'arrive en groupe à la
réunion de groupe et que je sache que il
ya un sujet sur lequel je ne peux pas
être d'accord avec quelques cohabitent
en
jeu pourrait être tendue
aiguisez mes arguments enfiler mes gants
de boxe
et non
givet sereine
je sais que j'aurai l'espace de
m'exprimer comme tous les autres et que
ensemble nous trouverons une solution
à laquelle chacun de nous n'avait pas
pensé
notre société ne nous apprend pas à
coopérer à prendre des décisions sans
chef
le collectif est une véritable
déconstruction de nos modes de
fonctionnement de notre manière de
penser
et cependant
en vivant en collectif il arrive un
moment où on se heurte aux autres
d'autres sensibilités d'autres manières
de réagir d'autres habitudes
au début de ma vie aux foules ans je ne
vivais pas toujours très bien
il à laver le sol de la cuisine commune
et il a accroché la serpillière au
magnifique bougeoirs en fer forgé qui
ornent la maison et cette eau bible
pourquoi tu fais ça
ou l inverse
bon j'ai chanter une petite chanson
paillarde hier au repas elle est dans
tous ses états je vois pas pourquoi
il y avait sa fille de 11 ans
de l'incompréhension en passant par des
prises de bec nous avons appris à nous
parler à nous dire ce qui se jouait en
ouf merci la communication non violente
est peut être petit à petit à nous
accepter
ma cohabitant a dit un jour nous sommes
arrivés des cailloux anguleux et à force
de nous frotter les uns aux autres nous
sommes poli
maintenant je suis très polis
l'acceptation de l'autre
souvent par l'acceptation de soi une
meilleure connaissance de nos failles
pour nous aider il ya l'effet miroir je
vois en l'autre les choses sur
lesquelles j'ai à travailler
alors c'est très simple si j'ai envie de
faire un reproche à quelqu'un baj
regardant moi ce que ça veut bien dire
et si l'autre est un miroir
l'habitat participatif est une véritable
galerie des glaces
et ça c'est pas facile tous les jours
alors êtes vous prêt pour l'habitat
participatif
si vous souhaitez apprendre de nouvelles
manières de coopérer et si vous pensez
que c'est le lien aux autres qui vous
apporte du bonheur au quotidien
alors vous êtes sur la bonne voie si
vous pensez que les obstacles que la vie
met sur votre chemin sont autant de
prétextes pour travailler sur vous
grandir pour être plus libre et plus
heureux
alors sans aucun doute le collectif est
fait pour vous
mais comme tout le monde n'est pas prêt
pour cela
alors non peut-être l'habitat
participatif ce n'est pas fait pour tout
le monde merci
[Applaudissements]